yes yeah out of the three artists out of
three I think it was Google as a hardest
then uber then snapped and I think part
of that was also the composition so
Google had I used a line that so there's
this guy called Hasib and he writes like
he wrote this blog post about like
negotiating and he says like before we
continue our video I just want to say
that we are sponsored by a hosting er
today costing er offers web hosting
services that is extremely easy to use
with a great user experience and also
they are the fastest web hosting
provider in the industry now the
onboarding experience really shows you
how easy you can set up your website
since they show you step-by-step how to
create your website and guide you
through the process so you can deploy
your websites in minutes so they are a
lamp stack hosting service so you can
easily set up WordPress websites or
choose one of their templates you can
also write your own PHP code if you want
and all you have to do is FTP it into
their servers you can also use their UI
so you don't need to use your own FPT
clients which is very very convenient
all in all I would recommend host injure
if you want to host a blog or a static
website since it's super affordable you
know it starts at zero point eight
dollars so eighty cents a month for all
in one web hosting and domain name and
you can set up in just under two minutes
with their services so if you want to
make your resume stronger and looking to
host your pusher project host enger'
might be for you
and good news if you're interested click
on the description down below and you
get 15% off your purchase break it down
to like detail steps again so let's do
like a screw Facebook ad estate engineer
so okay so when did you start to decide
like okay I'm gonna switch jobs and down
like what you do how many questions did
you do yeah would you do like before
uber blah blah blah like sorry before
the interview
yeah and like yeah they just talk yes in
from the beginning yes so I think it was
around the summer of last year 2018
where I first started thinking about it
so first I did explore transferring
but there was no like headcount we do
yeah so so then I started like writing
up a rough plan and then I was sorry I
was kind of studying but like not really
seriously it's not every day like in
Prior like July in August and then I
think I got a call from a Google
recruiter and day since I had
interviewed them before they let me go
straight to an on site and so that was
when I schedule it out like like I'm
almost two months out and so since I was
already studying for Google a time I saw
and apply for like as many companies as
possible so I applied or like replied
like around 20 companies oh yeah
and then so I just made a post about I
said all the numbers so my head
basically out of those 20 I had like 11
phone screens and then obviously 11
phone screens
I like past eight of them and then I
decided to do on sites with six and
there's nice I like that funnel my
channel looks totally different
mine was a uber which rejected me under
20 you're like two minutes now over
rejected me for a different team before
yeah so you applied for teams right yeah
yeah yeah just for context I asked Cyrus
to refer me to Ober and then within five
minutes they said thank you
yeah they'd even call you hustle Sonya
but yeah and then and then I also apply
it to other companies I guess I'm not
super comfortable sharing just because I
owned this YouTube channel but basically
it's two big companies and yeah so then
and then I did two phone screen and then
two on site and then two offers no nice
hundred percent I'm sure for fun yeah
except for uber but yeah yeah I knew I
wanted to do to get like a lot of on
sites for practice and then I also
wanted it for negotiation I got [ __ ]
lucky you know because because um yeah
cuz I went to like I'll just blur it out
you know when I went through that was
like my first on site and I like I thank
God I got it but yeah nice but I also
actually had a call
does something different they make you
do a coding challenge oh I don't and I
just googled the cooling challenge and I
found it and I just got me face with it
yeah it was totally fine I remember I
like Bart and I affair with the first
phone screen so it gave me actually give
you a phone stream yeah yeah I didn't
get the challenge yeah it was so easy
like they gave me the challenge I I just
like Alan I copied the question I pasted
it and there was a Chinese website like
yeah no yeah I got actually I remember
the phone number use one of the hardest
they I guess I got a late coat hard Oh
and then I barely got it I got a second
phone screen cuz I was borderline
already oh well at least they're nice
yeah and I heard like they do a lot of
like cultural interviews oh yeah
but yeah and I heard they pale very well
too but yeah anyways so after you did
you're on site and all of them yeah so
so which were the on site say you did
again if I had six on site so three of
them were Google goober and snap and
then three others yeah so so yeah so
uber was it like the code hard because
medium versus net which ones yes yeah
out of the three artists out of her
three I think it was Google was the
hardest then uber then snap and I think
part of that was also the composition so
Google had like all five rounds were
coding like data structures algorithms
where as uber had they had a system
design round and they had behave around
and then I think same with snap and I
had like actually study a lot with
system design because I really wanted
like a more senior level so because
Google is like all five coding I was
like it was pretty saw stupid yeah video
yeah so I also I also had like similar
experience with a company I also had
five five algal rounds like I think I
got lucky cuz because you know it's
either you know what you don't like once
right like there's always a trick to
these Allen questions you know and then
yes so then that one it was fine I did
it and then for the other company it was
like two coating rounds and then was it
three yeah it was to coating around
three system design Reese
one like behavior or likely a ship or
whatever that's called and yeah it was
[ __ ] long holy crap I think it
literally took from like 9:00 to like 5
mmm but for the system design I use that
rocking the inner yeah rocking this I
interview yeah I paid for that but I
realize I don't like every case they
have they always say the same thing they
do yeah it's about bike I guess it's
repetitions
yeah actually only helped me with one
question cuz like the system design
question at that company it's not always
like oh you know bill huh whatever right
sometimes he ask you something specific
like for example I think once they said
like oh you know you have this memory
space you get Bob Loblaw
well how should you like format the
memory so that right it's efficient blah
blah blah
well yeah or you have like a buffer and
something that and that was annoying
because I remember like when I was when
I was doing it you know at one point I
was doing it and then it's like okay
I'll stop you over here because you know
it took you longer than most people
I feel like system design is so broad
yeah like yeah they can go if it
specially was a specific team right they
can go really it was lame because like
yeah it was like a data infrastructure
position and I didn't even want to do
the infrastructure but they didn't have
any possession for like apps right right
yeah anyway so and then you got offers
from Google snap a noob er and then yeah
why did you choose uber yeah so yeah so
I got offers from five of the six and
then the three and serious contention
where Google grants app and so I ended
up choosing uber because well first of
all Google gave me a pretty low offer
so they're notorious for down leveling
and then uber and snap because they know
your true work well no I kind of
expected it cuz I bombed like one of the
questions and the Google's that actually
matter I think it does looks like mmm
yeah because I did I did really well on
uber and snap offer on sites and I got
like like top of the range for the level
offers so they the numbers are not
higher than with Google where the offers
already top or was it because you
negotiated no they're already top yeah
so actually yeah so actually with both
Google with both uber and snap the
offers were
like the base and equity we're already
maxed out and I think part of that was I
had actually done some like
pre-negotiation like I had like set it
up so that they knew that they would be
competing with all these other companies
so like both over and snap recruiters
knew that at Google on site and then
like I think that's one thing like you
don't like you can tell whicker's about
upcoming on sites especially they seem
like kind of impressive even if you
aren't sure if you're gonna pass it and
then once like even before they gave me
the numbers I had already told them what
I was expecting and like the other
companies offers so yeah I got a I got a
pretty high initial offer okay okay
they're just like digging to more - just
like TC negotiation yeah Oh in case you
guys don't know what TC is it's total
compensation if you go on blind you
wouldn't know what TC you know so TC how
did you like was it already at the max
the TC yeah so yeah so a TC I think
that's I think the most important thing
is knowing how much you're worth and I
think the yeah so like I said blind is
really good for getting that an idea and
also double staff why I you can see like
specific offers each level so I really
knew kind of the like max range and then
I knew that I didn't really care if it
was like I don't care how the offer
components were broken up and so like if
I could get a hardy component the
components are like base equity bonus
and then sign-on bonus and so I didn't
want to care how they split it up but if
I wanted like 20k more I didn't care if
it was like like sign-on versus base
because usually companies donate go
shape base as much so yeah so let's go
back to like exactly what happens so
which offer did you get first I think I
got like I got snap first yes yeah and
then and then they give an offer did you
negotiate them yes I think yeah I think
I know she ate it I I think what snap
they did raise the equity no I'm just a
little bit and then it became the max
and then but yeah I I had already told
so another things important I had told
off these recruiters that was gonna take
a while so they didn't try to pressure
me by saying like you only have three
days to decide and I think you will see
this in blog posts but basically like
never accept that that usually there is
buffing and if they aren't gonna fingers
print out company I'm say yeah but yeah
so yeah so I I told them it sounded good
but I'll think about it and also
negotiation you don't want to be like
it's not like a adversarial thing it's
kind of I could trying to find someone
it's a good deal for both of you so yeah
so I told them it sounds good but any
time to think about it I'll let you know
when I get like other numbers yeah okay
and then then you got over yes I'm
carless and that was a higher incent oh
well actually it's actually before I got
you bruh I had already gone so I guess
the company is D&E so I've gotten like
an offer from company D that was a bit
weaker and total compensation but the
base salary was like significantly
higher actually as I was able to use
that to say like based on this you guys
raise your equity and so that's one
thing we're like even if another
company's offer is on the whole like
weaker you can take a specific component
and say you know like I you know I
rarely really value a liquid liquidity
right now are like consistent like
steady state salary and so based on that
you know can you guys improve your offer
so yeah okay
and then you prove your snap offer and
then you got your uber offer yes and was
the over offer hired in its now so it
was it was roughly equivalent and silver
the recruiter like already knew exactly
what the snap offer was gonna be and
yeah so it was roughly quoting bits it's
hard to compare because uber is a
private company whereas Snap is public
right and so I I was pretty confident
goober was going to IPO
this year which I think to what turn out
to be true and then but then like a snap
is like public and their equity vests
every month so it's a lot more a lot
lower risk ba so at the same time like
high-risk to cuz snap wasn't doing that
well yeah so yeah I had to come up with
my own way of comparing the two okay and
did Eber increase their offer because of
your snap offer yes so actually yes so
the what they I was already at the max
and so I knew that the main thing I can
improve on was signing bonus I saw I
went on blind did some searching to see
if like it was possible and then I
eventually like pushed for certain
signing bonus and I used a line that so
there's this guy called Hasib and he
writes like he wrote this blog post
about like negotiating and he says like
so you have this long time running these
compete companies competing for you so
at the very end the final like strategy
should use is like because right now
your leverage is that you have these
other companies you have time in your
hand has an element and so if you give
away that time advantage then you can
like get something back for it and so
basically the way you do that is you say
I can out sign right now like basically
in the process of with everybody else if
you guys give me you know like 25k more
and then yeah and then usually they want
to I get it they close the deal right
away so yeah interesting so you got a
little bit up there yeah yeah yeah
so Indiana what was the tc4 like Snap
uber and like Google yeah so did it
depends on how you calculate it but
basically around through and UK for snap
and uber and then for Google about like
240k damn that's crazy
so 300k for like zapping uber and oh
yeah what level is that
oh four oh four oh well and that's
pretty much at the top yes printer show
the top damn okay